[Music]  sugarbear may have been preaching big is  beautiful on mama June from not too hot  but honey booboo is telling a different  story the other day we were on the phone  and so he was like I make all my grass  so I think yeah I'll come to it he was  like I was like Obama need a rag boy he  said you're gonna need a Porsche more  cuz it wouldn't hurt it wouldn't hurt  for you to lose weight and I think that  was most ignorant than they could ever  told him buddy did that make you hurt  were you kind of mad or were you I was  that mad of the point that he said that  because like I didn't get this shape  from not eating so what's your  relationship like now with sugar bear  and Jennifer your mom and I were talking  about it earlier a little bit um it's  hard for to say because I'm it's  non-existent it's not existence you guys  don't talk or see each other anything  he calls me any bring one so if there's  a blue moon outside he's gonna call